[Music]
and now I'm Diana I live in
Mexico City in Mexico and her
video production company for sale
would have been torture and these the
Facebook channel and Time Bears the food
in my country is an incredible experience
in Mexico we have a huge variety
flavors smells textures here in mexico
the restaurants have obviously opened
with all life safety standards
i don't go out in particular i don't
feel safe no it's not something i still
want to do it's
already in the morning i'm going to make
my classic coffee with  milk and my classic
fried egg on the bread and an expensive jamenéi box sausage
[Music]
and a glass of chlorophyll water with
peach and some synchronized with macho sauce
and now I'm going to play some
video games and I'm going to eat a
marzipan  a very very very classic sweet here in
mexico everyone knows it is already
night and for dinner i have decided to make
an equator of choco milk with banana the
best it already tastes super yummy it is a complete
room  a
win win
biden
[Music]
good morning them to Mexico City
eggs with bacon
chili serrano green
beans some grapes and coffee with milk
[Music]
yes
I'm going to make something super fast because
it's almost afternoon so I'm going
to make a recipe from that day when I
was in college with easy and
cheap tapestry baked toast a can of
tuna in chili while an old man mate for
dessert two cribs and to drink Jamaican water
[Music]
has sunshine and the truth is that I
don't have dessert  It's enough for me and he says eat a
chocolate to feed this little one
who is blooming here it's a
bonbon popsicle with chocolate
this device is like super typical of
Mexico and I'm a little hungry so I
decided to make me some quesadillas of
nopales with avocado it takes place in
joint sliders white horse in vertical
is serious and leaves us well on fire in
graffiti today is delivery day and I'm going
to the super pamper like every
Friday and I'm going to ask them there is a super  r
that I decided to order my
favorite chilaquiles from a restaurant that I
love chilaquiles
jaime sabines mart over chiquintad
haidar manga to drag notified
of them for so long delivery but they
I love tacos as very good Mexican they
are northern tacos I also ordered
golden carnitas tacos and they are a  delight
I also asked for a dessert plan a
soda nate that is like a cajeta sweet with
pistachio it is super super rich super
typical of Mexico to drink
horchata water so as not to drink jamaica water
or watch
[Music]
hello guys it's 19 o'clock  what am I going to
do talking class but
after working class I'm going to order something
supercopa
mmm
look this is a pozole it has
corn kernels pork with red broth
there I liked to prepare it that way I like to
put radishes on it a little lettuce a
a little chilito and a little oregano
with sun and red necessarily have
directv converse for free
for moments in question is to talk
super rating ha quer  gone as online buddies
I'm going to make some hot cakes
with condensed milk and a coffee with milk for
dinner this is my favorite dinners I know everyone
calls us altex for dinner but if in my
family we sometimes have hot cakes for dinner
rabinstein pan
is one more
like that  it is
I am going to make a hole and some tortillas
to accompany the tuna it is super life
michael barry bonds jaime i want to work
my great sun to have the reason is to
disaffect constitution because like every
Sunday also to order pizza
and then I like to cut the crust and
then I eat the thing
[Music]
honestly I don't think I'll make anything for
breakfast today because yesterday it was too much
pizza and I think that this week I'm going to
take a
turn and I'm going to make myself something super fast and
easy they're going to make potato taquitos now
be that the super healthy santa claus tacos
but think that it is the
quickest and easiest thing that I can do right
now but write
efe easter friday july more I don't know about
jason keller willing and video
I'm going to watch a little  with a series and I'm going to
eat our coast, delicious and more, it's
like a cake and chest while as a
kingdom of rings the leading role in the
morning I'm going to get ready to leave
living a little bit of the
city is shown
[Music]
there is no one  that I return home and well
ask what was coming a super
rich breakfast I ordered some tecolotes which is a
muffin with chilaquiles I also ordered a
couple of green tamales that's a
normal day in a green forest Mexico being
with friends and having breakfast together
nice
today  it's the last day
but more
i
[Music]
because they're very fun
white I hope you get a very
good sample of all the flavors that
exist in Mexico the wide variety of
dishes you can try and see you
soon
[Music]